Singing on a stage in front of thousands of employees,...
...Alibaba's Jack Ma is not your average corporate chairman.
He flunked his college entrance exam twice.
That may have been the last time Jack Ma set out to do something and failed.
Ma is 49 years old and was trained as an English teacher.
He learned the language by working as a tour guide and listening to Voice of America.
Since then, he started one of China's first Internet companies.
Later, Ma persuaded 80 people to give him $60,000.
And that was the beginning of what is now the Alibaba Group.
Alibaba is known for e-commerce both consumer and business-to-business.
But Ma has broadened the company's interests.
Alibaba is involved in cloud computing, banking, TV production...
...and even has an online music service.
Ma's personal fortune is valued around $13 billion.